die holding war hast du so verdienen
haus geschmückt was bist du denn mit
total authentisch mit man das einmal
weiß was passiert die gäste blieben
[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute
marokkanisches fingerfood wobei für mich
ist es auch schon fast eine
hauptmahlzeit wir machen nämlich bad
boots und das sind einfach so kleine
brötchen brote aus grease und dass wir
befüllt mit verschiedenen füllungen wir
machen heute alle drei wir machen eine
tour feststellung wir machen einen hack
verschulung und eine hähnchen füllung
und zuallererst machen wir nochmal den
teig und dafür brauchen wir auch nicht
ganz wenige und überschaubare zutaten
die schreibe euch alle ganz genauen
gramm angaben hier unten in die infobox
und ich fange jetzt an mit dem mehl ich
könnte durch auch meinem eine
küchenmaschine nehmen weil ich wirklich
einfach zeigen dass das ganze auch ohne
maschine funktioniert hier habe ich
weichweizen gries kommt jetzt direkt mit
dazu also eigentlich gibt die alle
trockenen zutaten erst rein ich habe
jetzt auch trockenhefe das ganze
funktioniert natürlich auch mit
frischhefe wenn ihr frische hierfür
nimmt dann einfach in etwas lauwarmem
wasser einrühren zusammen mit zucker als
nährstoff aber hier entfällt das hier
gebe ich nämlich zucker und salz auch
direkt mit rein jetzt wird das einfach
vorab so ein bisschen vermengen dann
verbindet sich alles gut und dann kommt
lauwarmes wasser dazu lauwarm einfach
aus dem grund weil sich der teil mit
lauwarmem wasser viel besser vermengt
ipads mit kaltem und ich bin dafür
einfach die sauberen hände
[Musik]
ich habe den teig jetzt wirklich nur
zwei minuten mit den händen geknetet
hier eine schüssel der ist super klebrig
bei einem normalen hefeteig kenne ich
gesagt jetzt braucht auf jeden fall noch
mehr mail bei mappus ist es so dass es
auf jeden fall so klebrig bleiben muss
denn der gries der hier noch drin
versteckt ist der quilt jetzt auf und
daher einfach ein tuch darüber lägen
also schön verschließen und dann
mindestens 45 minuten dann gehen lassen
wir die zeit habt dann wartet gerne 60
minuten ich mach nach 45 minuten mit dem
teig weiter und zeigt euch dann wieder
raus richtig schöne kleine brote
entstehen
nach 45 minuten total sieht unser teig
so aus ich finde es ein mega gut
aufgegangen wir müssen jetzt einfach nur
die saubere arbeitsfläche entweder
wählen oder in gries reichweiten links
könnt ihr gesagt wir nehmen das ist
vollkommen egal denn wir werden den
jetzt aufräumen und ausstechen meine
werden so circa acht zentimeter groß ihr
könnt euch dafür entweder ein großes
glas neben schüsse oder einen runden
ausstecher wichtig ist nur dass man den
teig jetzt nicht zu dick ausrollen da
ist ja hefe drin und der wird auch noch
mal so ein bisschen wenn wir den nicht
auspacken der wird auch noch mal so ein
bisschen dicker werden
[Musik]
nachdem ihr dann den teig ausgestochen
haben nehmt euch am besten wirkt einem
winkel palette dann könnt ihr das mich
einfacher anheben dann habe ich hier
noch so ein bisschen im gries
ausgestrahlt es geht auch wieder mehr
das ist auch kein problem wenn es
wirklich zu klebrig es könnte auch ein
bisschen mehr noch mal drüber streuen
als hilfe und das ganze dann noch mal
zugedeckt zehn minuten lang ruhen lassen
und ich habe jetzt natürlich so ein
bisschen überschusses dürfen nicht
verschwenden einfach hier noch mal zu
einer kugel zusammen rollen und auch
gerne nochmal 10 15 minuten zugedeckt
entspannen lassen weil ihm merkt dass
der teig sich immer wieder zurückzieht
das bedeutet dass es einfach nicht
entspannt genug ist und sobald er
entspannt ab auch nochmal ausbreiten und
ausstechen und noch ein tipp von mir
moment ich habe mir meinen ausrollen
stoppt guck mal grad das sind 6 mm und
das ist einfach die perfekte dicke
wundert euch nicht die werden gleich
nach dem auspacken noch ein bisschen
dicker nachdem ihr das habt entspannen
lassen zehn minuten und tempo kommt dass
in die fettfreie fahne ganz ganz wichtig
fettfrei und da werden sie von beiden
seiten schönen goldbraun gebacken das
dauert so pro seite ungefähr vier
minuten aber guckt immer mal wieder dass
sie auch nicht zu hell oder auch nicht
zu dunkel sind
[Musik]
wir starten jetzt mit der hähnchen
füllung ich habe jetzt so ein bisschen
was vorbereitet ich habe hähnchen sehr
sehr fein geschnitten weil sie sind
schon sehr feine kleine stückchen ich
habe die zähne vorbereitet einfach in
feine würfel geschnitten und jetzt bin
ich hier am herd gibt etwas öl in einer
pfanne und dann werden die zwiebeln
darin gedünstet und ich gebe auch schon
mal knoblauch mit dazu
[Musik]
ich gebe jetzt noch immer dazu
irgendwann könnte am besten stehen wenn
ihr euch einen löffel nehmen dann könnt
ihr da einfach die haut weg schieben
dann eine feine reibe und einfach mit
dazu reiben und da unser hähnchen jetzt
doch sehr sehr klein und fein ist
braucht es auch nicht lange ihr dürft es
nicht zu trocken braten dazu bei mir
reicht jetzt schon wirklich maximal
einer minute
so irgendwann dass ich jetzt darin
maschinen dünsten und dann kommt schon
die gewürze mit dazu ich habe natürlich
seid so einfach war ich habe etwas
gucken mal habe ich paprika edelsüß und
ganz wichtig russell hat das ist eine
arabische gewürzmischung dies ganz
typisch und wenn ihr habt gibt auf jeden
fall koriander mit dazu
[Musik]
so die hähnchen füllung ist fertig jetzt
geht es weiter mit unserer hackfleisch
füllungen dafür habe ich hier auch
wieder eine pfanne auf dem herd schönes
erwärmen und dann gehen wir da zu
beginnen auch wieder zwiebeln dazu
knoblauchzehen mit rein und ich habe
auch vorab schon eine rote paprika in
sehr feine würfel geschnitten die gebe
ich auch noch dazu dass es optional aber
ich mag das gerne
[Musik]
so die zutaten habe ich jetzt circa zwei
minuten lang dünsten lassen weil ich
allzu hoher hitze jetzt kommt unser
hackfleisch dazu ich habe jetzt hier
zufällig das magere wir könnten auch
gerne das fertige verwenden wenn ihr
mageres fleisch nehmen einfach ein
bisschen öl ausgleichen falls ihr merkt
da fehlt einfach ein bisschen öl wenn
ihr mögt könnt ihr an der stelle auch
schon mal tomaten oder paprika markt
dazu geben ich nehme ehrlich gesagt
immer das was ich gerade darf ist passt
beides wunderbar heute ist es paprika
markt nämlich auch dazu dann entwickeln
sich richtig schöne röstaromen
anschließend wird das ganze gewürzt salz
und pfeffer und wo tomaten sinn ist
zucker nicht weit das passt nämlich
perfekt ein bisschen zucker mit drei
nicht zu viel und nehme ich zum beispiel
persönlich noch paprikapulver edelsüß
klassiker und mein tipp sieben gewürze
passt perfekt zum fleisch und sobald das
ganze dann schön grün nicht gebraten
wurde wie man so schön sagt eingesetzt
wurde ist es auch schon fast fertig ich
gebe dann einfach noch passierte tomaten
dazu und das war's
[Musik]
die hackfleisch bildung ist fertig und
wir machen uns an die dritte füllung und
das wird eine typisch füllung dafür
nehmen wir natürlich thunfisch nimmt am
besten den im eigenen saft also nicht
den in bild und dazu gebe ich jetzt
direkt frischkäse und mayonnaise und
eigentlich könnt ihr dann selbst
entscheiden was sie noch dazu gibt ganz
typisch sind grüne oliven in scheiben
geschnitten das mache ich gleich auch
wenn sich seine größte oli für ein
komischer weise obwohl ich olivenöl über
alles liebe daraufhin hat sich das ja
noch ein nächstes und ich wollte mal so
richtig traditionell heute machen dazu
gebe ich dann gleich auch noch mais und
ich habe mir noch gewürzgurken die ich
sehr fein schnibbelt die kommen auch
noch dazu und eine rote zwiebel vertraut
mir das schmeckt super lecker da drin
das ganze dann noch mit salz und pfeffer
würzen wenn ihr mögt nimmt mein captain
fisch gehört wenn ihr das nicht auch
kein problem dann ersetzt es einfach mit
oregano ist selbst ein 1 1 ersatz dafür
aber das passt auch ganz gut
[Applaus]
[Musik]
also die boote haben jetzt doch so pro
seite sieben minuten gebraucht als die
fahne dann richtig auf temperatur war
dann wirklich nur noch 65 einhalb habt
ihr wirklich immer ein auge drauf und
ich habe insgesamt 24 boote
herausbekommen und jetzt werden sie nur
noch gefüllt was riecht so gut ihr müsst
das echt mal sich gerade ich mir jetzt
einfach ein messer am besten mit
wellenschliff dann kommt ihr da nämlich
ganz gut durch also nicht komplett durch
schneiden sondern wirklich nur so dass
ihr die dass sie die bad putzen befüllen
könnt und ich mache es jetzt so dass
sich bei der teamvorstellung noch
blattsalat mit rein nehmen können wir
einen theoretisch bei den anderen auch
ich mache das jetzt einfach ganz spontan
und wer das die gesagt befüllen und dann
wirklich wie beim catering so richtig
schön drapieren
[Musik]
also ich finde die sehen richtig gut aus
es macht extrem appetit man kann sie es
kalt servieren tatsächlich oder gerade
die fleisch heutigen sachen einfach noch
mal so wie sie sind in den backofen tun
einfach ich würde jetzt schätzen auf 60
70 grad vielleicht und dann einfach
nochmal so acht minuten lang oder sogar
ein ding dann könnt ihr das quasi warm
halten wenn ihr einfach noch ein paar
minuten puffer habt bis eure gäste
kommen und hier macht es super gerne
nach keine sorge der test wird kommt
haben sie jetzt gar nicht da aber später
heute abend werde ich auf jeden fall für
euch probieren lassen ich persönlich
sage an der stelle schon mal bis zum
nächsten mal auf die spitze
jetzt kommt mal ein tales das ganz
spontan aus dem wohnzimmer dann spontan
ganz vorn sowie sogar am essen ist so
die these machen besteht dass wir alles
ich liebe das dass wir alles vor kanada
bringen kann und dadurch kann ich es
vorher ist jetzt nicht eingespannt also
ich feiere die mega ich fand die
richtigen hast du von ihnen heraus
geschmeckt was bist du denn also ganz
ehrlich total authentisch du weißt ich
habe es viele marokkaner ich habe schon
oft gar nicht erst mal freunden bei
mamas und so und das schmeckt sehr sehr
sehr sehr sehr klein vergleich ist
inkontinent super also 10 cent bekommen
den koran das möchte ich auch raus
gehen also sehr sehr authentisch dass
ritter kitty hast du es toll gemacht
wirklich aber zum mittagessen form
anwendung ist es rein weiß wo das
passiert eben das ist echt mega
vergessene wenn das auf dem tisch steht
richtig beeindruckt nach machen leute
leiten und kommentieren das stimmt schon
einmal gehabt habe schreibt aufgegessen
weiter geraucht was ist dein favorit ich
weiß dass ich nicht alles geil also ich
kann das nicht entscheiden
[Musik]